hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agent Carter episode 4 video so we
had a Generalissimo sighting we got to
see Dominic Cooper again we got a lot of
new cool info on Leviathan and Peggy's
new neighbor Dottie Dottie was actually
really big one so I'm gonna start with
her first just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet so here
we go
so the showrunners confirmed after the
episode that Dottie is part of the KGB
Black Widow program or what would become
the Black Widow program I feel like
people saw her do that leg move and it
was like that looked exactly like
Scarlett Johansson so of course it's
Black Widow so if you came away from the
episode thinking that you were 100%
right so just to explain the Black Widow
program in the comics this is she pretty
cool they've Rick conned the Black Widow
characters history a couple times so the
Black Widow program came after they
created the Black Widow character so
rewind to World War Two in the context
of the show the Soviets are the new
looming threat not Hydra and the Nazis
the end of World War two kick-started
the Cold War Leviathan is behind the
crazy typewriters so they're one of the
big villain groups we know that the
Black Widow program is completely
separate from that in the comics that's
a KGB organization originally the the
Black Widow character started in the
1960s she went on to have all kinds of
adventures with Hawkeye and the Avengers
in 2004 they retcon her backstory in the
new continuity she was taken by the
Soviets as a child she was an orphan and
inducted into Operation Black Widow we
actually got some Black Widow flashbacks
in The Avengers 2 trailer so because
it's relevant I'm just gonna use him
when I talk about the Black Widow
program so her handlers took her to a
place called Department X this place
here with a bunch of other female
orphans brainwashed them and then train
them as assassins so whenever we're
seeing this in the trailer and she has
those really creepy sounding lines with
the bangs that's that's what's happening
they're brainwashing her as part of that
each of the Black Widow operatives gets
false memories implanted Black Widow
thinks that she used to be a ballerina
so that's why we see these ballerina
scenes in The Avengers 2 trailer
she's just remembering false memories
dottie on agent Carter is just an early
version of that Black Widow program she
also thinks she's a dancer too I would
assume they give them dancing skills if
they're gonna implant them with those
memories if they're gonna talk about the
origin of shield when I talk about the
origin of the Black Widow program
they're just nice and narrative simit
I know everyone wants to know are we
going to see the Winter Soldier on agent
Carter I'm totally not expecting it just
because sebastian stan is a pretty big
movie actor now so he's pretty busy and
they I think they're done filming agent
Carter I think they've finished the
finale already so of all the characters
from the current films that could cross
over on agent Carter Winter Soldier is
just the best option just because he's
one of the few that are the same age in
the past as they are in the future so if
you want to hold out hope for Sebastian
stand on agent Carter they could do it
at some point
as for what Dottie is doing so close to
Peggy my guess is that she's just acting
as a normal KGB spy trying to infiltrate
the SSR and maybe Howard Starks inner
circle it's just like the soviets
wanting to know what's going on that
doesn't make her Peggy's enemy or
anything like that but she's not her
friend either so moving on to top five
moments from the episode number five
welcome back Howard Stark it's a shame
they don't use more Dominic Cooper on
the show but I totally understand why
he's primarily a film actor he's usually
busy doing that stuff and he's way more
expensive than normal TV guest stars you
also have to consider how sometimes he
can overpower the narrative he's almost
like a supernatural character like look
at his supernatural abilities with women
like he has some sort of pheromone that
no women can resist and he can genius up
any device that he wants like he just
magic sup doomsday devices like they're
candy like oops one fell out of my
pocket so using him all the time would
be like putting Thor in daredevil it
would become like the Thor show with
daredevil his sidekick the whole opening
sequence was a really nice soft reveal
to I felt like a Peggy Carter that
Winter Soldier action scene like the
boat scene from the beginning where he
parcours the at everyone on the
boat moving on to number four
nobody cares about agent Sousa and he is
sad just look at that sad puppy-dog face
I mean admittedly I'm not rooting for
him as much as I think the show wants me
to they're positioning him is a good
person but he's just not quite there yet
the role he's feeling right now is like
the only person inside the SSR if it's
not a complete bag of dicks I won't
start rooting for until they starts
helping Peggy which i think is actually
coming soon I mean eventually he's gonna
find out who the woman with the dark
hair is the one mysteriously doing all
their police work for them I just I love
how none of the other agents questioned
the anonymous tips regarding doomsday
weapons it would be like someone handing
you a bunch of nuclear missiles and
you're not saying hmm I wonder what's
going on here this seems a little
strange
the scene in the interrogation room was
probably one of his best scenes from the
series so far he gets a lot more
sympathetic and we actually learned that
he can swing a mean crutch so I would
really like to see him in some more
unorthodox fighting scenes and I do want
him to join Team Peggy really soon
moving out to number three mr. mink
versus Dottie totally awesome black
widow style takedown you know even if he
didn't know she was part of the Black
Widow program the move she did here with
her legs is just like Scarlett Johansson
did in Iron Man 2 and then again in
Avengers I thought that he might be a
comic book character but all I could
find for mink was a female character
named Julie Steele so mr. mink seems
like a new character the show created
and then promptly killed off I did
really like his automatic pistol scene
as cool as all the stark tech is and
present day seeing all the classic tech
like all the iterations and gadgets they
make is really cool number two the
massacre it fin out teases a deeper
Leviathan plot so this was a little
harder to follow agent Dooley's mission
if you're confused Julie went to
Nuremberg to talk to a Nazi to find out
what the government was trying to cover
up at the battle of finow he has no idea
what love iesson is but all the dead
people on his board are tied to
Leviathan it's just the SSR people
haven't figured it out yet so it's
revealed there was no battle of finow by
the time the Nazis got there all the
Russian troops had been massacred I
think it all points to Leviathan messing
around with their own crazy technology
like maybe they did a weapons test or
they're testing a Super Soldier Serum or
some crazy Crimson Dynamo Suit precursor
it seemed like there might have been a
revolt like it was something inside the
Russian army maybe like a Hydra a Nazi
situation if you remember in the first
Captain America movie Red Skull rebelled
against Hitler and the Nazi Party and
kind of broke Hydra off as its own
organization so Leviathan could be doing
the same thing with the Soviet army it's
just in the comics Leviathan is like a
Soviet version of Hydra they do learn
that Howard Stark visited the
battlefield a day after the massacre so
he could have been just trying to figure
out what kind of weapon was used
it could be more stolen stark tech we'll
probably find out more about that in
next week's episode because they're
going to Russia like they're literally
going to Russia with the Howling
Commandos and my number one moment
Howard Stark has a vial of Captain
America's blood the way I took this in
the in the context of the show is that
they're just going to try and use the
blood to reproduce the Super Soldier
Serum a derivative or
just outright clone Captain America
there have been several versions of the
Super Soldier Serum in the Marvel Comics
but in present day like right now in the
comics the Falcon is Captain America he
took over as Captain America from Steve
Rogers he did that after Steve Rogers
gave him a blood transfusion giving him
his powers I don't know that they were
trying to reference the Falcon Captain
America that's going on right now but
also in slightly related news Luke Cage
got his powers in another replicated
version of the Super Soldier program his
was a little bit different someone tried
to botch the experiment and he ended up
turning into Power Man and yes we do
have to say it
PEGI stuck that vial of blood in the
world's worst hiding place so I feel
like that's gonna come back to bite her
in the ass at some point the way the end
of the episode just just the tone felt
like it had an air of finality but this
is the Marvel Universe and nothing in
the Marvel Universe stays buried forever
if you remember that was actually a line
from the agents of shield episode with
Peggy Carter it was the episode where
she locked up Whitehall and he said
nothing stays buried forever it's just a
nice callback to that here's my big
question for you guys do you think that
that vial of Captain America blood is
going to come back later in the series
or do you think it's like a red herring
and we're not gonna see it again I want
to believe it's the tip of the iceberg
like it's gonna lead into some big
Leviathan thing they're trying to make
their own super soldiers something crazy
but next week again like I said we're
gonna follow with the Howling Commandos
we'll go to Russia so be sure to
subscribe to get that video there
supposedly going to be meeting a
mysterious young girl with red hair so
take that as you will just to talk about
the Easter Egg so I already mentioned
Black Widow stuff from the Black Widow
program but the Stan Lee cameo reading
the paper we have seen pretty casual I
thought it might be another timely
comics reference back in the early days
when Stan Lee was first working for
timely comics but before they became
Marvel most comics were sold at
newsstands selling them in bookstores
and even comic book stores didn't become
a big thing till later if he did spot
any other Easter eggs in the episode
just write them below in the comments
but moving on to thumbs down there was
really like one big thumbs down and I
would say it's like you know Chad
Michael Murray like being an to
everyone in the SSR office I felt like
him speechifying to all those people
I felt like none of those scenes worked
really well I think the show will
address it in a satisfying way at some
point eventually like Peggy punching him
in the face
repeatedly I mean you just you can't
have him be that awful of a person
without letting her give him the
business end of a baseball bat
he seems really sinister too so I
wouldn't be surprised if he turned out
to be a double agent like ward style
where Ward turned out to be Hydra in
related news Game of Thrones season 5
trailer should be coming tonight might
be tomorrow I'll just I'll prioritize it
whenever it posts I'm also doing an
arrow flash DC QA so I'll do that after
I do mic Game of Thrones trailer video
generally I'm really pumped up going to
this weekend it's gonna be a really good
weekend get the Super Bowl to a lot of
Super Bowl trailers coming so while you
guys wait for all that of this stuff to
come just in case you haven't seen it
yet you can click here to rewatch the
Fantastic Four trailer I did a breakdown
and kind of explain how it pulls from
the ultimate comics origin story and you
can click here for last week's agent
carter video thank you so much watching
so let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you